good afternoon welcome along to this
ordinary meeting of the performance
policy and partnerships committee uh we
have an apology
uh from councillor kit uh and joining us
on zoom uh mrs coote councillor clark
and councillor abbott somebody like to
move the apologies received i'll move
the apologies
and seconded by councillor scout thank
you put that all in favor
carried
uh one item in the public forum from the
anderson park trust um mr anderson and
mr mcallister welcome along if you'd
like to come and take a
seat i think give us a chair thank you
the floor is yours gentlemen look thank
you uh i'm craig mcallister
[Music]
yeah i'm a
family descendant of uh sir roberts i'm
a great grandson so i
made impaired with the
robert anderson name i feel it's my
responsibility to
serve the trust and try and get the
house
back in
working order
so look thank you very much for the
opportunity to address you and take any
questions the um
for the for the brief period of time
we've got just a little briefly outlined
what we propose
and then just open it to questions so
obviously the house is being
strengthened at the moment and that's a
great thing and i think a lot of the
public of course is very keen and eager
to get back in
but getting it strengthened of course
just really gets the door open
we all appreciate there's still a lot
more work really to be undertaken in in
the interior of the property
it still will need a bit of a kitchen
upgrade one doesn't have a kitchen
and toilet upgrade and there's still a
bit of work to do on fire egress so
we're still not going to get the full
use and functionality of the property
from day one
so that's why in our material that we're
prepared
uh to support occupation we're proposing
a staged approach so initially it'll
only be we're only proposing open it on
limited terms possibly probably in the
weekends
and that'll be for about a year or so
and then to a full week and then
ultimately seven days
and during the course of getting it open
we propose to open it up for
the public to have a look through it
and then we're proposing to have a
full-blown open day when the weather
allows to have a good opportunity for an
event that's suitable to
re-open it to the public
and from there we'll also look at making
some capital improvements that the
property is funds permit
like anything the trust is run by
volunteers
and of course the voluntary group
is never without risks to the council
but
we're pretty um
confident that we've got the skill base
to run the operations in the house and
also to set the kpis agree the kpis with
council and work with council to achieve
that
and i must just add that we've been
working with the council now for
last four or five years
and look it's been a journey but the
council's always been very very
supportive
and more recently with richard mcguire
involved uh we've had a very good and do
enjoy a very good working relationship
so
we believe that our relationship's on a
good footing and we sort of look forward
to working with the council in our
partnership approach going forward
thank you
councillors uh it's an opportunity if
you have any questions for mr mcallister
or mr anderson
councillor scout thank you for your
thanks team just in the sense of the
interest craig going forward with
some of the remedial work going on has
there been any um
more activity or interest from the
outside operators
given that we are it is being seen to be
moving along
there's been a bit more activity or a
bit more interest being shown by the
community or the wider sector and the
sense of
the building possibly being used in the
future once we once you have your
stepped approach going forward
um not from operators so we ultimately
we want to develop better facilities
within the house and and possibly bring
in a cafe or
operator to run that side of it i
haven't received any expressions of late
but i have received inquiries from
people wanting to use it
so i mean that's quite positive people
are sort of um aware that is
getting to the point that it is
available for use
and so i've received emails from people
wanting to know sort of what costs and
when it's going to be available all
those sorts of things so it's been a
positive approach in that
thank
context
councillor partner uh thank you chair
yeah craig um as far as furnishings go
for inside you you've got your own
you've got your own art collection that
you that you're going to put up uh it's
a bit of a moot point so
how did someone take it
well there was the art collection left
by kathleen kirkley who was
a daughter of
sir robert anderson and ladies with
anderson she donated an art collection
to be held
at the house right
that's with the uh
invercargill art gallery
um and it's a discussion to be had as to
whether it ultimately rests okay so
apart from uh what about you still got
the furniture some i remember quite
intriguing furniture yeah so there's
some furniture stored at the moment i
think it's down in the old museum area
uh and the council's indicated they're
happy to make that available to the
trust to put back into the house and use
but it'll still
be retained the ownership will still
mess with the council
but from our point of view we're not
really so interested in ownership of
these things per se it's just having the
right it's just making it look and feels
that's the right thing when you're
walking and there's still only one
toilet is that right yes
well one ladies one grandchildren
yeah and so obviously there's going to
be you know it's a it's a moving face
there is still work to be done and we
know that we have to accept that but you
know we're happy to work with what we've
got to get the place open and available
for the use for the public again and i
think that's what the public really want
i think you're right we
um
the the telecom art awards do you
remember those they used to be there
were you right yeah about
and that's the type of function that are
you looking for that's sort of
yeah um not the only function but that
is the sort of function that we would
want to make it available for absolutely
people wanting to hire the house
and use the house for functions or small
conferences or weddings or
some form of anniversary type get
together
we've also
in discussions with with richard and
councils might want to clarify that with
him talked about how the council might
want to use it as well for its own
purposes and so we'll the the
arrangements will facilitate that so for
example if counselors want to have a
meeting out there then obviously they'll
be made available for that or for
anybody else within the council to watch
we're actually looking for an admin
building something
yeah so so at a generous discounted rate
any other questions councillor lewis
graham can you um drop the mask and pull
the mic
i have to lean forward
um
can you just clarify the state of the
kitchen at the moment you said the
kitchen upgrade but as a at a commercial
kitchen stage where they no
unfortunately i didn't think so the art
gallery people completely gutted what
was the kitchen so there is no kitchen
so any functions would have to be
external catering correct which
everybody yeah um
you know says it's doable and i accept
that but ultimately we do want
some form of
heating type kitchen where people can
bring in plates of hot food keep it warm
fridges to keep stuff cool and cleaning
facilities and the liking so we don't
necessarily want a full-blown commercial
kitchen
other questions
if not thank you for the update and
thank you also for the feedback on how
you feel things are progressing very
positively now um that's that's really
good to hear
so you know i've had the same feedback
in reverse
on on how things are progressing with
the trust so uh thank you for your
continued involvement and interest and
for coming along to the meeting this
afternoon
thank you very much mr chair and um you
know on behalf of the trust we just want
to acknowledge the input that the
council's
had and uh
and you know it's been a very good
process to date and and we look forward
to it continue
thank you thank you
councillors that brings us to the
minutes of the performance policy and
partnerships committee meeting on 12
april
somebody wish to move the
true and correct councillor scouts miss
reverend cook
any discussion
if not i'll put the motion all in favor
against
carried
whoops
is this mirror available we've got today
and steve welcome along thank you very
much for the report
thank you mr chair i'm your worship
counsellors
on behalf amir and i we'll take this
report as read
but i do just want to recognise the
efforts that a number of staff have
played in this and as you can read
through the report
this process has taken
some two years from an idea created from
a small group of staff to where we are
today
and a number of those staff don't work
with us such as darren edwards
so just want to heat their efforts
[Music]
if i may make a couple of points um
this is a a
a direction i travel to help our staff
and our team
build build awareness and build
knowledge and skill but also build
confidence as we
improve our partnership with emu maori
and the roonaka locally
and so it's not a mandatory training
requirement
but the feedback that we've had from the
survey
indicates that there's a strong desire
to improve knowledge to improve skill
and to build confidence so when we do
engage
with te kangar with te reo
that our team can do so confidently we
know what we're doing we know what we're
saying and we know when to say it
we also when not to say things as well
and
i think this is a really key focus of
this strategy it's about building our
organization's capability and so uh
we're really happy to take any questions
from here thank you so if i can kick off
is this a process that was initiated by
staff wanting this opportunity
yeah correct uh back in 2020
2020 yep that's about the same yet um
we had a staff forum and a couple of
staff got together and thought that
actually we didn't really
reflect uh the moves that the
organisation needed to make in terms of
our partnership with maori so they got
together and they started identifying
what were the causes what were some of
the opportunities
and that's how we've come to this
strategy today
externally
and
can i ask what sort of feedback you've
had when
we've engaged with ewe and they've been
aware that
council has been making these moves
i'm mindful we've got two members from
that arena and i might if you're okay mr
chair passed to pass to those members
absolutely pania would you like to kick
off
uh just in support of the document uh
private just following when um even and
i came in
we
met in regards to the document
we made some subtle changes um
and also acknowledged that there was no
manufa
representation on the group
however insane that i think just what
the staff have been proactive about and
developing and pulling this money
language strategy plan together
is
um amazing you know
it was
of what they've done to date uh also
um
even though we
spoke about diabetes we didn't want to
cause confusion right
therefore we've actually taken um the
approach around
using the a generic
uh
maori approach so that it encourages
people and enables people to
feel comfortable in
um
yeah so no we we i mean i can speak on
behalf of the south people i can speak
on behalf of her
i i've supported the strategy
going forward there's probably only a
couple wee things i would add into the
um
which is the outcomes and actions and
that would be
linking it to professional development
or your your performance
and development reviews in some way or
form
as well as um
job descriptions going forward
but i just think it's amazing that um
that we're on this journey and that
we've got staff that
are driving it
thank you reverend cook
um
yeah
so
i possibly was engaged a little bit
before
hanya just threw some um conversations
from outside
particularly
through my engagement on smack board but
i too would like to
thank the staff
for driving the initiative themselves
rather than having
somebody come with an edict from on high
i think when you own something when you
help design something then you feel much
more committed and engaged with it
um
learning today is a journey
it's a journey for everybody no matter
whether they start with near one or
whether they start when they're 36 like
me
um and you never stop learning
so
i
look at this and say that this is the
first step of many steps
that i'm happy to walk beside you
and encourage
but not impose what my real is on you
but open the option there um we have
some people who have dialects of their
own within the team and i'm really
mindful that as a living language
people need to be able
to
embrace what their tupana left them not
what my tupan left
so um the uniqueness that is
that is the kaitahu real
um it's appropriate that we put it on
stuff that reflects the city but for
staff who are learning to speak and who
are learning to do things
i just applaud the fact that you are
doing it and i am so grateful
to those whose energy drove it because
it doesn't come
out of nothing you have to have a
passion and you have to really want to
see it through
to have made all the effort and work
that you have done so kamehameha
thank you to those who have
worked on this
most important
um
kappa for all of us because it is for
all of us not just for staff
thank you
let me take the opportunity to mihir
miller as well
whose name sits on this report uh thank
you for your mahi in preparing this and
bringing it to council and
bringing in this change opportunity for
our staff it's it's valued so i'm
very happy to move the three
recommendations on the agenda if
someone's
reverend cook it's open for discussion
councillors
councillor clark and then councillor
cracker
yes steve just some clarification um
on what paneer and evelyn said um both
had a slightly different twist for me so
going forward are you
looking to the links that pania talked
about
that
te reo
would be linked to job descriptions and
professional development
um
does that mean there'd be a requirement
for all staff to go down this path given
that evelyn said that
you've got to want to go on this journey
i mean i've been involved with
an ngo where we had about 18 months of
this
and it was really positive but we didn't
force it we we let people come forward
they had a desire so when when uh palmio
suggests
professional development would that be
on an individual basis or is that
something you want across the whole
organisation
thank you councillor through you mr
chair
um
i think that's a really great question
and it's one that we've talked about um
it's very much an individual
approach at this point
we recognize the journey and as
the two representatives of well point
out this is an individual journey based
on individual
capability and experience and confidence
we're not at a point as an organisation
where we can make this a structural
uh requirement and it hasn't even been
discussed i think we're at the starting
point
uh and we'll follow your
as your example and indicate indicated
it's a it's an evolving
um capability that we're seeking
yeah thanks to steve because my
experience is it
compulsion doesn't work
and as people
get excited about it and some will
that will encourage others to get
excited as well
thank you just before i come to
councillor's cricket and sopa uh mrs
coote you had your hand up
just in regards to the response i think
i was more future thinking
and looking forward um
because when you write cultural
competencies in a plan
what are you measuring
so so that was why i rate i
raise um
that
that makes sense
thank you
sorry oh sorry steve yeah just through
you mr chair look one of the reasons why
we undertook the survey
was to establish a baseline of of
competence and baseline of confidence
and awareness
and so we do have some good data now
that we hope to go back to in about a
year's time to see how we shifted the
dial
so uh we we do hope to be able to
measure our progress through this
strategy
thank you councillor cricket
um
thank you mr chair
um
i'm just mindful that even this morning
um we had a submitter say to us
um why would you have maori translation
on
your submission documents or your
consultation documents because nobody
understands that and that's just
from my perspective so devastating
because this is one of new zealand's
national languages it's a lost language
because of
wrongs of the past and it is absolutely
up to us and thank you for showing
leadership on this
um and making it so because if we don't
revive and do everything that we can to
bring mario back then future generations
will just be very much like that
gentleman sitting in front of us today
going
nobody understands that so
um
the fact that we're even showing
leadership on it like in my other role
um
that i have in my career one of my
people that i sit on the leadership
group with said to me even the council
uh are looking at doing this and
bringing reo or te reo maori and naming
and things like that and what we do in
the corporate world so showing
leadership i think on this is just
incredible and i really um hear what
you're doing so thank you for bringing
this
thank you councillor sofa
thanks mr chair um
i also wanted to pay tribute to the
staff who've got us to this point um the
revitalization of the maori language of
toriyama
is just so important for us as new
zealanders and i'm also wanted to refer
to the comment from
one of the submitters this morning
and many other comments i've heard over
many years in political life um about
toriya being a dead language and why
would any new zealander want to
learn it and why is it important in our
culture
it is um
i have welsh heritage as well
i dream of the day
when the weather we can say of to rio
that like the welsh language it has been
revised
and and revived and you
travel in wales and you hear school
children talking
in welsh on public transport
of course you may know that welsh is now
compulsory for children from five to
sixteen in schools at least as a second
language
and that has been an example of the
importance of the revival of language of
of treasuring and saving atoma that was
also a disappearing language which is no
longer a disappeared language
um
i'm really thrilled we've got to this
this point i'm really thrilled that
staff have played such a big part in
making sure that we have the strategy
i really encourage you to to keep
developing it um
i'm really pleased that we are seeing a
much more bicultural look to this whole
council
to the way as staff are much more
confident in speaking to rio
and i didn't want it to pass without
saying thank you
to every staff member who has
contributed to bringing it to the table
um and to conclude i'll just say uh kota
manakai atimiro
nonati nahira
koti manakai ati matarangi nona tiau
the bird who eats of the marrow the
forest is theirs
the bird who eats of knowledge the world
is theirs
thank you for bringing back
a great part of new zealand's knowledge
the value of the rio cannot be lost
thank you uh
reverend cook then councillor passenger
uh cured mr chair just wanted to clarify
um for the benefit of council clerk
miss coach and i are not at differences
we just come from a different place and
we're looking for different things
i
believe that as governors it is not for
us to say
what should be in an employment contract
or should be part of a performance
appraisal unless we are talking about
the chief executive
who is the only person whose performance
appraisal is our business
um as i understand the world
um so whilst i
look forward to the day
when i
some competency in terrell and meona te
kanga and knowledge of the treaty and
all those things are written into the
job descriptions of staff that this
organization employs
that is not within my purview i would
support it i would endorse it i would
encourage it but i cannot impose it that
is my perspective um
and so um for the benefit of
um councillor cut that is the reason why
i didn't go
i didn't look at that as part of what i
thought was the um
aim of this particular
policy however should it arise from the
adoption by the staff in the
organisation
i i would applaud that and i would be
there to support it as actively as i
could thank you thank you
notice
mrs cootes found a new icon as well
uh councillor pottinger
thank you um
so far we've talked about uh staff and
and and them coming on board with this
but obviously
we we can't
you have to balance it with the elected
member side now here we sit with the
council
meetings that reader
the prayer that's written on a
board every day and and uh we
basically in our meetings
down in my chair there is no
and basically we
i mean
it's it's pretty blank what we do and so
for elected members and what how we
operate who is the
is it up to the mayor to lead that
because obviously
you really need elected members to
choose their own way forward is that
right rather than
try and
say well you're going to do what staff
are doing
yeah
mr chair
councillor pottinger is raising
questions that are
best asked of the governors and not of
the staff and it was our intention as
staff that
possibly best colloquially put we lift
our game
and that this be the subject of
discussion with an incoming council
as a change in the next trinium
the purpose for it coming here was a so
that you would
see it a little more in the organization
b
we are keen to see turayomari being
incorporated into the identification of
meeting rooms so we didn't want you to
get lost when you were looking for that
which is currently referred to as the
chief executive's meeting room
and there'll be other changes but most
of them will be left
at the governance level until the
incoming council and the next training
okay the reason i the reason i raise it
it
that this is an ultimate leadership
thing so
in an ideal world you would see the
mayor bringing this to the table
and getting every everyone on board
rather than
a resolution coming to council and you
have to vote on it
which would be quite awkward you know so
i'm just wondering if you know obviously
that has to come as claire said
but there needs to be a balance and the
staff are into this now and obviously
we've got to we wait to october
and then
so if i may it would be appropriate for
us perhaps to
ask
that an opening karakia could be gifted
to us
um we can't select one
uh it would be and if i can
leave that as a discussion between our
mona fennel representatives um
to create less of a
cultural desert in the meetings
um would be a positive step forward yeah
but i do believe i'm trying to get out
as
it is the mayor who would leave this as
it's come down from the ce
i think as you're seeing any counsellor
can take that step
yeah yeah i'm just saying
yep
any other comments
counsellors
it's been moved and seconded uh was
seconded by reverend cook
i'll put the motion all in favor
against carried
thank you
well said mirror
jamie and anna
the performance report
welcome along to the meeting
who's leading off
okay so what we've got here is the
performance report for the nine months
ending
31st of march 2022
um i'll take the reporter's read but
we'll just do our normal view highlights
out of the report
um
i'll start with the financials and then
we'll move on to the level service side
of things
so
up to march we've got a surplus of 8.2
million now this
is inflated mainly because of revenue
we've received from
subsidies for capital program
so they are just one offs and they're
not going to be continuous but we can
only recognize them as the capital work
has been completed so
with the good chunk of the work being
done this year that's why we can
recognize it this year and why we've got
a big surplus
they will come back
by the time we hit the year end to about
5.6 million
uh capital side of things so we're on
track to be our largest spin in about
the last five years
um so we're currently sitting at 34
million spent um year-to-date um
projecting to get up to about 52
and
because of the sed street and the street
scrapes stage one hitting their peak
spans
we're looking very likely to hit that
50k
50 million mark
um net debt side of things um so we're
on track to be 38.6 million by year in
now throughout the year we've um
done a few things so term deposits um so
what we've been doing is we've been
actually taking some of those funds out
um and using them to fund the capital
expenditure
um so that's dropped from about we've
got used to have about 35 million of
term deposits that's currently sitting
about 25 and there'd be another seven
we'll pull out in the next lot of
maturities which is july next year
we will have some funds come in the last
quarter for the sales of some properties
um so that will prop up our
cash
bank balance initially
but that will be used up as well
and then we've also drawn down some
borrowings to
fill some short-term loans to the
invercargill central limited
as agreed
for the city centre and that is just a
short-term
loan so it will be repaid to us um over
the next few years
i'll pass over here
in terms of the levels of service uh
you'll see there have been some that
have moved to looking like they will not
be achieved in this year
the big impact of course is covert that
has hit the numbers attending the
libraries and the pools and places like
that so uh we have a bit of a blip in
many cases this year uh and so we'll
yeah that's probably the notable change
in the levels of service otherwise
things are tracking pretty similarly to
previous quarters
thank you
so initially we can get excited when we
see the surplus of 8.3 million until we
realize that most of it's tagged
pretty much yes
thank you
councillor partner
thank you cheer
um just referring
to the delivery of um
51.9 million for the year so that
that target that you're on target to
deliver
is it
are those capital projects meeting
budget are they are they also on budget
i mean they're being delivered but are
they excessive of what they originally
planned yep so all the big road map
projects they're all still within their
um initial budgets that were set within
that long-term plan
okay so this is not affecting right no
it's more the phasing of when the spin
happens right this is the phasing of
when the spend happens so you're not
we're not seeing price increases here
yet when we look at the
annual plan for
june
to the next june
we're seeing
we're seeing 88 million dollars yes so
some of that is to do with the phasing
um some of it is to do with new projects
so the museum is in there
yeah just the explanation in the
in the annual plan is is
doesn't reflect that
yeah it reflects
yeah increasing prices supply chains
all sorts of stuff like that um but that
doesn't seem to match up so that some of
those are flowing through as well um so
for
instance
there have been some new projects which
come in which will have the higher cost
than which we initially
had thought
but most of those will be able to be
covered by the overall
project so
what i'm trying to say here is um
yes there are pressures on
but at the moment we're going to be
managing within those existing budgets
to cover those
but the plan for next year is
higher um we've had pricing already for
that have we so yeah for some things the
the the reports on the nine months
performance yeah yeah but i'm looking
forward at this stage we've got that yet
to come with deliberations
patricia what i would just reiterate to
councillors is that
this is about this current year we're
still going to go into the deliberations
about what's changed but what jamie i
think is trying to say here is we are
having some
on some of the non-road map projects
where they're slipping in time frame so
they're going to move into the next year
so while we might have lower delivery
this year that will come in to next year
and why we've got such a
a potential
little blip
and with a higher delivery required next
year look look my basic question is the
separation between
delivery issues which i understand and
price escalation
two different things
so from the big projects we've got them
covered from the
smaller projects um there will be
pressures put onto those ones
but we're managing the delivery of those
smaller ones
so we're not over stepping out
boundaries of the budgets right
thank you
councillor clark
thank you chad just a couple of
questions for jamie
just want you to run back over the
initial bit that you said about the uh
year-end position and it's influenced by
money that we're holding for
projects that we've yet to complete and
yet to totally fund what what's your
forecast for year end
on which part sorry
on the on the total budget the total
operating budget we've got for council
are we in a potential surplus situation
or not so we're in
surplus if you include the capital
subsidies
if you exclude those capital subsidies
we'll be in a deficit
so so how much deficit are we talk about
about one million
i'm going to change that
two three
it's about two million
as it comes back in line
me two main deficits
are you suggesting that putting aside
the
projects that we have external funding
for
and we have yet to spend all the money
that on our i guess what you call core
other business we're heading towards an
overspend of two million dollars
i wouldn't say it's an overspend
um covert has hit some of our operations
this year
um and that has affected our revenue
as well
we've tried to do our savings to meet
those revenues decreases
yeah i appreciate that
so
when i look at the performance summary
as of 31st of march and the financial
performance i notice that employee costs
and other expenses which sit in the same
area
are
1.6 million dollars overspent
is that a big chunk of the 2 million
that's overspent so that's under spent
not overspent
so when it's a positive variance it
means it's good
so when you suggest to us that we've got
a two million dollar gap between what we
forecast at the beginning of the year
for income and what we
spending to date
where's the bulk of that two million
dollars coming from
um so half it is coming through the uh
revenue line and half that's coming
through this cost savings we're
well restricting the cost we spend
so it's about a 50 50 split between
revenue and expenses
uh bear with me again
um if we start off um the beginning of
the year with ten dollars in revenue and
we we forecast on a balanced budget ten
million dollars of expenditure
how does reduced
income
and how does savings that you're
suggesting we're making on the expenses
side of it
create us a two million dollar
imbalance
oh sorry i got you now um
yeah so
with the quarter four there is normally
a lot more spin that comes through as we
do the year-end um
process um so we also have like annual
expenditure which only hits that last
month of the year
um so we factor those into the forecast
so
it may not look like it now
but when we get to the year-end and
annual report it will
come back
so again just want to clarify that
because it doesn't make any sense to me
so um when you do an initial
budget preparation before a financial
year starts off are you suggesting that
um
you just basically take um
12 and you make it a dollar a month or
do you factor in
costs into the last quarter which fall
within that quarter that's first thing
and and i don't know what the last
quarter cost will be is
if you are suggesting that we still have
um an expenditure that exceeds our
revenue by two million dollars
so from the on the phasing side of
things um so we do
phase where we can so when we know
specifically when costs are going to be
spent we will face those
if we are a bit more uncertain then we
will spread
that phasing across the year evenly
um so that will
explain that
last quarter um
step up an expenditure because we know
there's a lot of
expenditure in that last quarter um and
as well as the one-offs that come
through as well from then a reporting
site
i i guess just as a final suggestion
from my perspective i'm not speaking to
other colleagues
it would be helpful to have a an update
somewhere along the line to this report
that clarifies um that two million
dollar overspend because to me it that
overspend can only be generated in one
of two ways
insufficient income and you've suggested
covert has impact on that so i accept
that
but also that we haven't
been able to claw back the expenditure
on an equal amount and that would create
an overspend so
using a very simple example
10 million 10 dollars worth of income 10
dollars worth of expenditure we realize
we're only going to get nine but we
haven't been able to call back the
expenditure cost to nine so we've got a
one million dollar overspend
and it'll be helpful for me to know
because i
still don't know from what you've told
me uh where these extra costs are coming
out
so
i'm pretty confident jamie never
described it as an overspend
no well there's a two million dollar
deficit and there's there's a huge
difference in the terminology there
um yeah
so
just as a clarification chair um
certainly if we get to the year end and
there is a
two million dollar difference between
our income
and our expenditure at month 12
we will have to find two million dollars
somewhere i assume it will be our
reserves or out of our investments
to make the payments in the last month
that was a question
was that a comment or a question sorry
counselor clark um i'll answer this one
jeremy um that will not be necessarily
the case because we know this you're
looking at a p l where we will actually
be borrowing because there'll be
payments that we'll be making that will
be balance sheet
and also j we are taking out eliminating
the subsidies and grants from this
discussion and they are actually cash
that we receive so it does allow us to
make payments in that last quarter
i'm looking at page 28 of board books
and on that
though does appear at the their forecast
to your end is showing that there are
other expenses so in several areas of
operations they're expecting to
significantly to spend slightly more
um or 700 000 more than what was
originally planned
and with that together with the
reduction in income which you can see
under the income from activities line is
the two million which jamie's speaking
about and those are in a couple of
particular areas and i can't remember
them off the top of my head i'm hoping
jamie can
solid waste i think is one of them yeah
splash palace um just with the lockdown
periods and also the close for the
during period so we've lost the revenue
from that space as well
um and then yeah the civic theatre so
they don't have the um the shows and the
bookings like they used to
um yeah the various activities most
activities have had some sort of impact
at some stage
thank you
one final one final question if you can
be with this chair so just want to go
back to my original question a couple of
minutes ago
if we get to the end of the year with a
position that's
um two million dollars
greater expenditure than we've had
income and i understand what you're
saying about the income that's covert
driven
um will we be in a position where we
will need to find two million dollars at
the end of the year
when the last month
patricia do you want to answer that one
no
you don't want to answer it i will
answer it i think the answer is no we
won't need to we have
we will be in a cash
positive position
cool thank you that answers the question
councilman pottinger um just some
clarity chair around the increase in
solid waste now i'm assuming that it's
solid waste in the redmond
which because otherwise going through
the transfer station is paid for
and that would be there wouldn't be any
increase because that's user pays
but you're saying there's a million
dollar increase in the weights that
solar waste collected
um so it's
so the recycling
and the landfill costs so the money that
because the volumes have gone up um
particularly in the landfill um so we're
seeing a lot more charging from that
because of the weight it's gone through
um and also it reflects the um
the recycling contract
changes as well
from what was initially put into the
long-term plan
right because everything as i said
everything going through the transfer
station
is painful and would cover its cost
getting to the landfill the only stuff
that's
unpredictable is the red bins because we
don't know
what people are throwing out and that
could vary dramatically yeah and we have
to pay for that regardless it's a fixed
rate charge
so obviously
um i
a million dollars a lot of money so i
can't imagine the recycling
increase is over 500 thousand so you're
saying that we've got this variation
in um
in just domestic waste
from the um
what have been consistent yeah
percentages what i've been informed from
the managers um
they the costs have increased from
compared to where we were with the
annual uh long-term plan numbers
initially
um the contracts have changed
um the cost um charges have
changed as well so that's that million
dollars is reflecting some of that as
well as the volumes and council i'll
just jump in here we are i'm
investigating that at the moment so we
will come back with an update on that
one because i'm aware that when we
negotiate
well when i was on waste net when we
negotiated prices with the landfill they
would the landfill would take a hitch
they would give us three years of a flat
rate and they would win or lose
according to their costs so
we shouldn't really be called out
on
solid waste
i mean we shouldn't be yeah so i can
take that to the manager and we'll
talk through that
there's there's been a lot of change in
waste management and there's more to
come watch the mfe space
thank you
um
look we don't actually have a mover in
secretary for the full recommendations
yet so let me kick that off i'll move is
there a second
of sopa right now are there any further
questions or comments
if not it's good that we've had some
questions and challenges for the report
thank you um
all three of you for your answers i'll
put the motion all in favor
against
carried thank you
hayden
noise policy review
thank you for the paper uh counselors
will have read it but if you could just
provide them with a quick overview
thank you mr chair before if i may uh
introduce jillian cavanaugh to the
council so she's recently been appointed
as a manager of environmental services
and is the owner of seed noise control
policy
welcome and thank you new owner of sid
noise control policy
thank you cool so the noise control
policy uh was due for routine review and
we've completed some analysis to see if
it still fits through purpose
there were 101 noise complaints made to
council in 2019 with 97
of these coming from private residences
by using the graduated approach in the
policy to compliance and enforcement
there only needed to be 164 excessive
noise directions issued
infringements abatements and equipment
seizure
all in the single digits
we believe this is evidence that the
policy and our approach is working well
whilst reviewing the policy no major
issues were identified
we did identify some areas where we
could take a good policy and make it
better
we've clarified some points to make sure
there can be no ambiguity over when an
abatement notice can be issued
we've added in some statements on noise
that is covered by other legislation
what happens if c's equipment has not
been recovered after six months and
further defined what unreasonable noise
means
we present the noise control policy
today with two options for council
to adopt the policy of consultation with
the community
or to adopt it as it stands without
consultation
hundred and sorry a thousand and one
complaints is a reasonable number and
can affect all sections of the community
while we believe the policy is working
well and only
recommend minor changes
the public could have differing opinions
on this for this reason it would not be
unreasonable to adopt the policy for
consultation with the public
conversely we do not think this policy
will see high engagement
from the community and given recent
trends we'd be expecting low numbers of
submissions
if the policy were to be adopted without
consultation this presents low risk and
is an appropriate option as well given
the circumstances
we're happy to take any questions
thank you and thanks for the options i i
guess one of the things that we're
aware of as we've gone through a few
processes of late is
getting towards consultation fatigue
and making sure that when we are
engaging with the community and
recognizing there is a difference
between engagement and consultation
that we are doing so for
stuff that is front of mind um and i
guess as community sounding boards if we
were aware
of
extraordinary concerns around noise
control um you'd have no pun intended
heard from us more
um but we haven't the fact that the
numbers are trending low that there are
what would be
the expected complaints about a noisy
stereo or a noisy car or
someone who's decided to start a welding
business next to their neighbors or that
sort of thing
is is not out of the ordinary but the
fact that you've also taken the
opportunity to to tighten up around some
of the definitions is also really useful
because you know if we can find areas
where there's a bit of ambiguity if we
can tidy that up then this is a good
opportunity for us to do that
um
i'm happy to move that we receive
the uh the report noise noise control
policy review
and adopt the policy
without consultation if there's a second
i'll think about it
councillor emerson had her hand up first
but it's open for commie
councillor pottinger
um when i would speak against adoption
without consultation i reckon it's
a very public matter
noise
noise variation is a very tricky thing
because you cannot put a decibel level
on it because it's relative
to the ambient noise that you're in so
if you live in a very very quiet area
with low decibel background noise then a
change of
change of say 10 db is incredibly
noticeable but it may only be still
a quiet noise and subsequently living in
the centre of town the noise the ambient
noise levels much higher and you don't
notice other noises so it's that it's
that difference and i think
that we need to give the public
and allow them to put feedback in about
this
it's critical we do it with everything
else and the fact of bypassing this
i think is uh it's not good governance
that's my view
i should
any other comments
well let's test the feeling uh we have a
motion on the table and that is to
receive the report and adopt the policy
without consultation but with the
changes as indicated
i'll put put the motion all in favor
please say aye
aye
against
yes
councillor pardinger councillor lewis
would you like your names
and i am as well sorry thank you
councillor clark
three against the motion is carried
thank you for the report
thank you thank you
[Applause]
which brings us to the activities
reports
which one of our beloved group managers
wants to kick off here oh kiara koto
thank you through you mr chair so uh i
think the report
um mr macquarie you're welcome to
pop up the front thing
um
so from the customer environment group
you'll notice it summarizes the
different activities that we have in
place and you even see some visual
evidence of some of the matters we deal
with out at oriti beach
in terms of the submerged vehicle
uh i just want to acknowledge the
breadth of activities that the team
actually cover off but also that we have
made some progress on the property file
digitization project with the
appointment
of a vendor and
what they've been able to discover for
us is that we can
fast track this project so we'll have
access to the files
all going well within two years well
within the time frames that were
thought to be what we we would have been
potentially a four-year project we can
bring that down and within budget so
i think that's a real positive for
invercargill and includes working with a
vendor from a national vendor but in a
local space so something positive that's
good news
thank you mr mcfar
go to koto um obviously some trends
right across our facilities about a bit
of a dip through to because of uh covert
that we're all familiar with but it's
also some positives there as well
we are monitoring about how we
collect the data and present it back to
you because purely uh physical visits uh
not our entire range of services that we
offer across leisure and wreck so we're
going to look at different ways to
engage and capture how people are using
our services
the thing i'd like to draw attention to
is the progress at the museum for
housing and packaging up the contents
it's currently sitting at between 88 and
89 so we're well on track to
reach our goals for that particular
project
thank you
any other speakers
counselors any questions of the
activities report
no uh in that case would somebody like
to move that the report is uh
received councillor rabbits and seconded
sorry
councillor amundsen thank you
there's no further comments i'll put the
motion all in favor bye against
carried
thank you for that
uh councillors i'm not aware of any
other items are in public so i'll move
that we go into public excluded
to discuss the confirmation of minutes
of the pe session of performance policy
and partnerships 12 april the anderson
house occupancy
property investments update and
invercargill city holdings limited
purchase of shares
for the reasons as outlined under
section 72172b
second that mr chairman councillor clark
you have your hand up
yeah did you just one one brief issue
and it may not be resolved at this
meeting but when i look through the
cluster of papers that were presented by
the finance team for the nine monthly
review
there doesn't seem to be a treasury
report attached which there normally is
and that lists the um
uh the cash investments that we have
sitting
so is that an oversight or is that a
patricia um
for the last two quarters we've changed
and not included the treasury report and
the report to ppp but it's included in
the financial risks report to risk and
assurance
because that reports more from a risk
perspective so more appropriate to go to
that committee
thank you
thanks
okay uh back to the motion to move into
public excluded it's been moved and
seconded i'll put it all in favor all
right against
carried
thank you we are in public excluded and